karim ha desarrollado un nuevo método
para medir niveles de colesterol que no
incluye ningún procedimiento invasivo
como extracción de sangre eso está muy
bien las regulaciones se establecen que
la prueba deberá estar correcta el 99%
de las veces deberá estar correcta el
99% de las veces por lo que tiene que
verificar que su método cumple con los
estándares tomo una muestra aleatoria de
100 personas midió el nivel de
colesterol usando su nuevo método
comparó los resultados con muestras de
sangre que se tomaron a las mismas
personas encontrando que eran los mismos
95 por ciento de las veces dado que las
muestras de sangre siempre son correctas
él concluyó que su método es correcto 95
por ciento de las veces eso parece
razonable por lo menos para la muestra
que tomo a la luz de los resultados
karim tuvo que probar la hipótesis de
que la prueba es de hecho correcta 99%
de las veces
así es que probó la hipótesis de que la
prueba es de hecho correcta 99% de las
veces el realizó 100 simulaciones
generadas por computadora de muestras
aleatorias de 100 pruebas requiere
muchos genes
así es que hizo 100 simulaciones de
muestras
y cada muestra simulaba los resultados
de la prueba de colesterol de 100
personas está usando una computadora que
hace simulaciones basadas en la
suposición de que la prueba es correcta
el 99% de las veces para cada muestra se
simula la prueba de colesterol para 100
personas y se tienen 100 de estas
muestras así que suponiendo que el
porcentaje real de resultados correctos
es 99% con objeto de encontrar qué tan
probable es que una muestra tenga 95% de
resultados correctos los resultados de
las simulaciones se muestran abajo que
indican los resultados de las
simulaciones en relación a la
probabilidad de la hipótesis de que la
prueba de karim es correcta el 99% de
las veces bien sé que esto puede
confundirte porque tenemos las palabras
prueba pruebas cientos pero lo que hizo
karim con la muestra que tomó de 100
personas su prueba resultó acertada el
95% de las veces lo que él quiere saber
es cuál es la probabilidad de que esto
suceda suponiendo que su prueba es
correcta el 99% de las veces
así es que establece una hipótesis
él supone si supone si supone que su
prueba que su prueba es correcta su
prueba es correcta el 99% de las veces
es la hipótesis que está probando
entonces lo que quiera averiguar es cuál
es la probabilidad
cuál es la probabilidad de que esto
suceda cuál es la probabilidad de que
esto sea correcto pues si la
probabilidad de esto si la probabilidad
de obtener esto es muy pequeña entonces
podría considerar que no está cumpliendo
con la suposición no está cumpliendo con
el estándar no se puede considerar que
esto que se está suponiendo en la
hipótesis sea verdadero si la
probabilidad de que esto ocurra es muy
baja si la probabilidad de que él haya
obtenido los resultados que obtuvo son
muy bajos no se puede aceptar la
suposición de la hipótesis veamos eso
como interpretamos lo que nos está
mostrando esta gráfica de aquí entonces
recuerda la computadora está simulando
100 muestras 100 muestras y cada muestra
consta de 100 personas déjame aclarar
esto aquí tendríamos la muestra número 1
la muestra número uno luego acá
tendríamos la muestra número dos iba a
haber 100 de estas muestras y para cada
una de estas muestras lo que hace la
computadora es son 100 personas por
muestra
1 2 3 así hasta llegar a la persona
número 100 y para cada una estas
personas la computadora lo que hace es
suponiendo que el 99 por ciento de las
veces va a estar correcta la prueba la
computadora utiliza un generador de
números aleatorios que es como tirar un
dado y el 99 de los 100 casos el
resultado va a ser que la nueva prueba
coincide con la prueba anterior pero de
repente hay un uno por ciento de
probabilidad que indique este no
coincide aquí por ejemplo esta tiene 99
correctas y una incorrecta por lo cual
está entraría en esta categoría que
tenemos aquí así es que esta muestra
esta muestra que tenemos aquí
corresponde voy a hacerlo con otro color
más bien otro color así es que esta
muestra de aquí corresponde digamos a
este punto y si en la siguiente
simulación también se tuvieron 99
correctas y un incorrecta por ejemplo la
muestra número 2 sería este punto de
aquí supongamos ahora que en otra de las
muestras en otra de estas muestras de
100 personas no hay ninguna que no
coincida todas coinciden todas son
correctas entonces entonces ese caso la
muestra que tiene 100% de resultados
correctos podría ser quizás este punto
que tenemos aquí así es que vemos que
basados en la suposición de que hay un
99 por ciento de probabilidad de que los
resultados coincidan 99 por ciento de
probabilidad de que la prueba sea
correcta él obtuvo todos estos
resultados y aquí podemos ver que de las
100 simulaciones que él ejecutó ninguna
ningún arrojó el resultado que karim
obtuvo aquí parece ser entonces que si
haces esta suposición la probabilidad de
obtener el resultado que obtuvo aquí es
muy muy baja así es que para mí o para
cualquier estadístico e inclusive para
cualquier persona con sentido común
estos resultados los resultados que
obtuvo tanto experimentalmente como en
la simulación nos indican que la
probabilidad de que la hipótesis sea
correcta es muy muy baja por lo que la
probabilidad de la hipótesis de que la
prueba de karim es correcta el 99% de
las veces está es realmente baja
concluimos entonces que la probabilidad
del hipótesis es mucho muy baja y esto
basado en los resultados de la
observación y de la simulación y esto lo
que indica es que hay que rechazar la
hipótesis